[موسيقى]
التحرش الجنسي الظاهره منتشره في اوساط
العمل بالاسود لكنها تبقى من التابوهات
المغلقه والنساء اللواتي لا يملكن اوراق
اقامه هنا اكثر عرضه لتلك الانتهاكات حيث
يجد صاحب العمل نفسه امام فريسه سهله
مجرده من الحقوق فيجرى على التمادي عليها
بالقول او الفعل
[موسيقى]
هذا ما جرى مع هذه السيده وهي مهاجره غير
شرعيه من اصول عربيه تعيش مع عائلتها في
باريس تعرضت للاستغلال والتحرش من قبل
صاحب مطعم كانت تعمل لديه تجربه مريره
عاشتها سلمى وهي في الثامنه عشر من عمرها
عندما سلكت اول مره طريق العمل غير المرخص
به والتي دفعتها في النهايه الى التفكير
بانهاء حياتي
[موسيقى]
بعد كم يوم صار يسال اسئله محرجه
بعدين صار يحكي كلام يعني غير مباشر كنت
اعمل حالي مش فهماني بالمره بطنش بس بعد
فتره صار كلام مباشر
صار يقل الادب كثير وصار يعني يعني يعرض
مبالغ يعني اليوم يعرض مبلغ وبكره بيزيد
عليه وبعده بزيد عليه قلت له انا مستحيل
انا جاي اشتغل ما بدي
مستحيل راح اسوي
علي بالشغل مثلا
فتره يعني صرت لما اجي افوت على الشغل
ببكي لما اطلع نفس الشيء
يعني لما وصلت معي لمرحله انه
حاولت انتحر
طلعت من الشغل
فما خلفته هذه التجربه من شعور سيء ما زال
محفورا في ذاكرتها
[موسيقى]
تتشابه القصص الى حد كبير جاد ايضا كان
شاهدا في مكان عمله على محاوله تحرش حصلت
امام عينيك
وصاحب المحل كثير الاسود
[موسيقى]
وتقول لي انا بحاجه بسيطه
للصراحه هي ما معي ورق فهي مجبوره تشتغل
بالاسود فكان كثير هذا الموضوع قدامي كثير
مزعج يعني كان انسان يطلع انه ممكن المراه
تكون امه واخته اي حدا والبنت اضطرت توقف
عمل لانه هي ما بدها تقدم له شيء لهذا
صاحب العمل هو وعد انه اذا بتساوي كل شيء
معه بيعطيها عقد عمل بساعده بالسكن بيساوي
لكل شيء بس هو كذاب من البدايه هو بس بده
غلط معين
[موسيقى]
مهما كان الظروفها لكنها اكثرهن لا يعلمنا
بذلك
ليس عندها اوراق انها تعرضت للتحرش الجنسي
اذا كان تحرش جنسي الامور
سوق العمل مليء بقصص الانتهاكات عبوديه
مخفيه في مكان ظاهره الحداثه وباطنه لا
يختلف كثيرا عن ما هو حاصل في بقيه اصقاع
الارض
[موسيقى]